today's sentencing of former minneapolis
police officer derek shovin
shows how video from body cameras can
play a key role in trials
cameras worn by officers and bystanders
cell phone footage helped lead to
chauvin's conviction
for the murder of george floyd the most
recent study on body camera usage found
nearly half of law enforcement agencies
in this country had them in 2016
yet deadly encounters have continued to
rise
with black people more likely to be
killed by the police
jeff began spoke to officers about body
cameras and whether they think
the recordings improved policing
dallas police officers terence hopkins
and mary lavender
have been on the force to combine 56
years and are leaders in the black
police association of greater dallas
we represent the change in law
enforcement we
we first acknowledge that there are some
problems in that we need to move forward
with you know positive solutions not
just the same old
historic you know we're the police and
this is the way it is that that's not
good
so we are for change in a positive
manner
among the change we spoke about was the
push in recent years for police worn
body cameras
mary what do you think the opinion is
among
rank and file officers of body cameras
well i think
in 2021 i think that they they believe
it's a it's a good idea
body-worn cameras have saved a lot of
officers jobs
it works both ways it can protect you
and save you if you're doing your job
the right way
but guess what if you're doing your job
the wrong way it could also be the end
of you and it should be
what did i do wrong like this 2019
incident in north carolina
where a 66 year old woman was dragged
out of her car by her hair when she
didn't immediately stop for police who
said that she had been speeding
stop i have a right to stop you because
you're being suspicious also in 2019
police body camera shed light on the
death of elijah mclean
who was walking back from the
convenience store when he was
forcefully detained they do know they're
being watched
wake forest university law professor
kami chavis is an expert on police body
worn cameras
police warm body cameras are not the
only solution
to police reform really addressing
police violence in our country is going
to come down to
addressing police culture who do we hire
what are we asking them to do and what
is their relationship
with the community a recent study
published in the journal science found
that a diverse police force can help
improve how officers interact with
civilians
the study found hispanic and black
officers made
far fewer stops and arrest and use force
especially against black civilians less
than white officers
we were one of the first large
organizations to have body worn cameras
andrew walsh is an assistant sheriff
with the las vegas metropolitan police
department
in 2017 the department participated in a
study that found
body cameras saved departments thousands
of dollars per
officer each year by helping them
investigate complaints faster
it also reduced complaints overall from
civilians and reduced use of force
reports
the cameras you know obviously give us
the ability to hold people accountable
for their behavior
but they also give us the ability to
find things that we can do to not just
correct behavior but
improve our training both hopkins and
lavender know
body cameras are just one part of the
policing equation
we hire our people from the same place
everybody else the human race
and there's bound to be some guys in
there that's doing it wrong what do you
do in situations like that
you have to be able to professionally
intervene for a long time
there has been that history of well you
don't correct a good senior officer
field training option i'm a rookie you
know you kept your mouth shut
uh we don't agree with that we disagree
with it and now we're taking programs
uh training programs to help us
make sure that changes in the culture
sometimes change is needed
change is good so i don't have a problem
with reform
it needs to be defined a little bit
better
so the public understands what that
means but like i said
change is good for everybody it's so
interesting i
i mean i thought what the wake forest
professor said was was really important
she said it you know it comes down to
who do we hire
what are we asking them to do and what's
their relationship with the community
absolutely and it's fascinating how the
body camera can feed into the training
because now you have footage of maybe
problematic incidents that you can then
teach against
in a classroom setting an officer
speaking up against bad policing exactly
that's how you really change the culture